- You worked with our
friend Snoop recently.
I love Snoop, another guy that is just
the nicest human ever and so talented.
So, how did that come about?
- So, I've known Snoop since, shoot...
Since before I was doing standup,
I had been around around him.
We really got to know each
other when I did Snoop Dogg's
"Bad Girls of Comedy" for Showtime,
which I think is now
is on Netflix, I think.
But it's been out for what?
Like 13, maybe 15 years ago I did it.
And we've been friends ever since.
And ever since I'm always like,
"Snoop, we need to do a song.
Let me get in the music video.
Let's do a song.
Let's do a song."
So he was like, " Yeah, sis.
Bring something to the table."
So, I brought one song to the table
and that's the theme song now
for the "They Ready" series
on Netflix, the comedy series that I did.
And now we just did another
song called "Look Like",
and I can't wait for y'all to hear that.
It's me, Snoop, Lil Wayne.
It's fire.
(audience applauding)
- (clapping) I love that.